you may think that the mean value
theorem is just this arcane theorem that
shows up in calculus classes but what we
will see in this video is that it has
actually been used at least implicitly
used to give people speeding tickets so
let's think of an example so let's say
that this is a toll booth right now your
honor you're on the Turnpike and this is
a toll booth at Point a and you get your
tote you get a you reach it at exactly 1
p.m. and the highways computers and
stuff register that let's say you have
some type of a one of those devices so
that when you pay the toll it just knows
who you are and it read it takes your
money from an account someplace so it
sees that you got there at exactly you
got there at exactly 1 p.m. and then
let's say that there's and let's say you
get off of the off of the toll toll
highway the Turnpike let's say you get
off of it at point B and you get there
at exactly 2 p.m. I'm making these
numbers very easy to work with and let's
say that they are 80 miles apart so this
distance right over here is 80 miles 80
miles and let's say that the speed limit
on this stretch of highway is 55 miles
per hour speed limit speed limit is 55
miles per hour so the question is is can
the authorities prove that you went over
the speed limit well let's just graph
this I think you know where this is
going so let's graph it so let's say
this right over here is our position so
I'll call that the S axis s for position
and that's going to be in miles and s is
its you know obviously S doesn't really
stand for position but P you know it
kind of looks like Rho for density and D
we use for differentials for distance or
displacement so s is what gets use for
gets used for position very often so
let's say s is our position and let's
see this is T for time T for time and
let's say this is in hours
and let's see we care about the interval
from time going from time one time one
to time two time to I'm not really
drawing the axes completely at scale see
let me let me just assume that there's a
gap here just because I don't want to I
don't want to actually want to don't
make you think that I'm drawing it
completely at scale because I really
want to focus on this part of the
interval so this is time equals to two
hours and so at time equal one you're at
where you're right over here the let's
say this this position is we'll just
call that s of one and a time to a time
to your this position right over here
you're right over there and so though
your position is s of s of 2 you're that
coordinate right over there and that's
all we know that's all we know well we
know a few other things we know what our
change in time is it's 2 minus 1 and we
know what our change in position is we
know that our change in position our
change in position which is equal to s
of 2 s of 2 minus s of 1 minus s of 1 is
equal to 80 miles the change in position
is 80 miles so let me write that and
we'll just for simplicity assume as a
straight highway so our change in
distance is the same as our change in
position same as change in displacement
so this is 80 miles 80 miles and then
what is our change in time over our
change in time
well that's going to be 2 minus 1 2
minus 1 which is just going to be one
hour over one hour or we could say that
the slope of the line that connects
these two points let me do that in
another color
the slope of that's the same color the
slope of this line right over here the
slope right over here is 80 miles per
hour
slope is equal to 80 miles per hour or
you could say that your average your
average velocity over that hour was 80
miles per hour and so what the
authorities could do in a court of law
and I've never heard a mathematical
theorem cited like this but they could
and I remember reading about this about
10 years ago and it was big very
controversial the authorities already
said look over this interval your
average velocity was clearly 80 miles
per hour so at some point in that hour
and they could have cited they could
have said by the mean value theorem at
some point in that hour you must have
been going at exactly 80 mile at least
frankly 80 miles per hour and it would
have been very hard to disprove because
your your position as a function of time
is definitely continuous and
differentiable over that interval is
continuous you're not you're not just
getting teleported from one place to
another that would be a pretty amazing
car and it is also differentiable you
always have a well-defined velocity and
so I you know I challenge anyone try to
connect these two points with a
continuous and differentiable curve
where at some point the instantaneous
velocity the the slope of the tangent
line is not the same thing as the slope
of this line it's impossible that's the
mean value theorem tells us it's
impossible so let me just draw so we can
imagine let's say you know I I had to
stop to pay to get to kind of register
where I am on the on the highway then I
start to accelerate a little bit so
right now my my instantaneous velocity
is less than my average velocity I'm
accelerating the slope of the tangent
line but if I want to get there at that
time and especially because I have to
slow down as I approach it as I approach
the Tollbooth the only way I could
connect these two things well let's see
I'm going to have to some point I'm
actually at this point I'm actually
going faster than the 80 miles per hour
and the mean value theorem just tells us
that look if this function is continuous
and differentiable over this interval
continuous over the closed interval
differentiable over the open interval
that there's at least one point in the
open interval which it calls C so
there's at least one point where your
instantaneous rate of change where the
slope of the tangent line is this
same as the slope of the secant line so
that point right over there that point
looks like that right over there and so
if this is time C and that looks like
it's like at around 115 this the mean
value theorem says that at some point
there exist some time where your where s
prime of C is equal to this average
velocity is equal to 80 miles per hour
and doesn't look like that's the only
one it looks like this one over here
this could also be this could also be a
candidate for C